Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d', Seita.
This program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Today's Maestro Hook,...
...a good conversation piece you can use with a foreigner is...
...the Western art of exaggeration.
I'm sure you know, but Western people like to talk things up.
They always say things bigger than it seems or they always exaggerate stories.
Now remember, the reason they do this is because...
...this is for making the conversation more interesting.
And the reason they do that is because they want you to enjoy the conversation,...
...so don't get insulted.
The size of the conversation may be a little bit bigger, but enjoy the conversation.
And at the same time, when you're talking,...
...maybe you can exaggerate a little bit too, alright?
So, today's Maestro Menu.
Get your hopes up.
I got my hopes up.
I'm getting my hopes up.
Don't get your hopes up.
Okay, and next.
A letdown.
Oh! It's a letdown.
Such a letdown!
Alright, Native Lines.
You know, tomorrow's restaurant is gonna be really good.
Oh! I got my hopes up.
That restaurant yesterday was a letdown.
Use English like this and you can be speaking like a native,...
...and you'll be a native maestro any day now.
Alright, thanks a lot and see you next week on Native Maestro.
Bye-bye!
It won't be a letdown.